[Music]
hi all this is an interview with clara
meister who is the first author of the
paper typical decoding for natural
language generation this paper i believe
is really important because it presents
a new sampling method that makes
language models output much more
human-like texts i've already made a
review about the paper if you haven't
seen that yet check it out clara has
seen it and were able to dive directly
into the matter this interview was very
cool i learned a lot as always if you
like leave a like tell me what you think
in the comments and i'll see you around
bye bye hey there today's sponsor is the
course on introduction to graph neural
networks this is a course by my friend
zach jost who is an expert in graph
neural networks he's packed all his
knowledge into one course that will
educate you on both the theoretical and
hands-on practical aspect on graph
neural networks graph neural networks
are really important they're definitely
one of the most interesting areas in
deep learning right now they've also
powered a lot of recent advances in
scientific breakthroughs such as alpha
fold protein structure predictions or
better traffic predictions if you use my
link you'll get a 15
discount on the course enrollment is
open right now and lasts until april
first or until spaces run out alright
let's get into the video now see ya
hello everyone today i'm here with clara
meister who is the first author of the
paper typical decoding for natural
language generation clara welcome very
much to the channel thank you and thank
you for having me
this was a really neat paper i have to
say i have just finished my last
interview not just now but i finished my
last interview about a system called
blip and what they said is essentially
they have a system that generates
captions for images in an automated
fashion and then they have a filter that
kind of weeds out the crappy captions
and they use that as a means of
generating more high quality data and
they
and many others before them have found
that how you sample from a model like
from the language model they've trained
matters a lot specifically
they told me that nucleus sampling in
their case was really a defining factor
in getting more of a diverse
sample set and they particularly
compared it to greedy sampling and to
beam search which they found super
underwhelming
and i've come across a lot of systems in
recent times
for example alpha code as well i don't
know if you know how exactly alphacode
does what it does i don't either but
from the paper i could gather that they
sample a lot of potential solutions and
then they reduce those down by filtering
and clustering and again there they rely
heavily on being able to sample
diversely and to sample you know many
many different things and i've for a
while now thought you know maybe our
sampling objectives are wrong
for certain applications namely for the
applications where we actually are
interested in more of a diverse output
rather than the most likely output and
along came your paper which essentially
exactly plays into this and suggests a
new method so i was super happy
to see this i think it really hits sort
of a nerve of the time um if you if you
would pitch it like the elevator pitch
for the paper what would you say about
it
um yeah i mean i would say that uh
i mean specifically for language
generation i think with these large
models that we've been training um that
we when we're generating language from
them we kind of need to take into
account like what
what we really want from the model what
our objective is
um and and also what we just normally do
when we're when we're speaking when
we're writing like how we use language
um and i mean
trying to think about having like this
you know what a model and what these
models are is essentially like
probability distributions over strings
right and that's kind of a strange
concept right it's like that's not
probably how
we imagine language in our heads um but
i mean
there is some like evidence in
psycho-linguistics that that's kind of
actually a pretty good uh metaphor for
how language is represented in our head
um and then i mean how we then go from
that to generating language um and what
the characteristics of the language that
we typically generate are i think you
know we really want to take that into
account
uh when we're trying to generate
language from these models
um yeah i mean if you ask me to like
say if you just ask me to say something
randomly
right i mean it's
like what am i going to say i'm probably
going to say like i don't know i mean
that's
like i don't i don't
it's like these really common phrases
but if we want something more
interesting like if you want me to say
something more interesting then i'm i'm
going to
not just pull like the most likely
sentence out of thin air i'm going to
try to convey information in what i'm
saying
um and you know i think that these
models have
uh sort of learned
what
how to do that implicitly
and we can ask them then to
try and do this in a similar manner to
how humans do um yeah
so you pretty quickly get to this notion
of uh typicality which is a notion from
information theory you connect it to
various disciplines in psycholinguistics
but a typical message as far as i can
understand it is well as the name says
one that you would expect to see from
sort of a communication apparatus but it
is do i understand this correctly is one
that you expect to see
if you
if you assume that the communicators
want to transmit uh the optimal amount
of information
yeah is this the the core assumption
behind
sort of the
how we think about communication between
humans yeah i mean so
one important thing is like typicality
in in the context of communication
channels um is really only defined in
the context of
a message here you know some sort of
message that you're conditioning on um
and trying to convey
so and here i mean especially when
you're like sampling from a language
model without having like this this uh
implicit message that you're
conditioning on um you know in the
background uh i think it's kind of hard
to
really
you know quantify what
a typical message in natural language
should be and i think we're very careful
to
say that there is this nice intuitive
link between typicality and uh
you know how humans use language and
what type of strings we might expect
when using natural language
um
but you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of aspects of human
language that don't really fall into
um the paradigm that
you can really apply typicality to
and yeah you so you you inspire let's
say by this notion of typicality or
you're inspired by so you define the
notion of a typical
message and that is sort of the the
average information content you would
see
i made a bit of a characterization in my
video by the way we have to inform the
viewers that i use the old archive
version
and you just updated it
and you corrected essentially all the
the little criticisms i had about
notation and things like this um just to
get the lore right it wasn't me that
caused it
you did it ahead and uh and then and
then
i
so
like
my advisor always says that like every
single paper out there pretty much has
like math errors in it oh yeah um
it takes a critical eye to find them it
does it's super easy to just
glance over them not realize it
well i think i think it was actually
straightforward the paper is really
easily readable so when we when we think
about how humans communicate and and
let's assume for a moment what you say
that
in your hypothesis here any given word
should have an information content close
to the expected information content
i.e the conditional entropy given prior
context
in other words we expect this difference
to be small in human-like text and you
also say that the human goal over here
is to transmit information effectively
while also minimizing the risk of
miscommunication
i made a bit of an example right here as
if i explain math or if i explain the
chain rule to someone who does and does
not understand math is this an
appropriate example this is an
appropriate metaphor for what you're
going for um or is this is this totally
off no i mean i think in in a way that's
right um i mean i think that also that's
actually perhaps even
more related to what we described later
on um
which is like the rational speak speech
act which is you know how we we also are
uh taking into account
um the listener right when we're when
we're forming our messages um so i mean
that's definitely a component that's
taken into account so we'll modulate
um the amount of information
that we are conveying
uh to basically
like
you know
to account for what the other person
might know and i think that you can kind
of model that in different ways you can
say that for i mean in in your case like
uh i think how you put it i think is a
totally valid way to
see it um
in that case we can say that the
information content
um for the speaker is going to be much
higher
than for someone else so
i mean yeah i think that's a good
comparison
so this notion of the expected
information content is is pretty
important here and we say okay if i'm at
a certain let's say i've ordered half a
sentence and then i look at the
distribution of the next word and that
distribution is just the distribution of
the language itself if i understand this
correctly so i have my training corpus
which supposedly is all of human
language i analyze it in my head i
determine what's the conditional
probability for the next word in the
training corpus and then your claim is
that what i do is i don't actually
sample from that distribution
i'm going to adjust in inside of my head
the distribution that i sample from to
to words that closely match the expected
information content my question is why
why do i do that like i see the problem
with always picking the highest likely
word right
if i if i have a broad distribution like
this i don't want to do that i don't
want to just pick the most likely one
however why can't i just sample from
this distribution it seems like enough
times i would actually you know pick
some other words that is also
completely fine
yeah i mean so first of all um
i think one thing is
when we're forming language um
we are i mean
we arguably aren't like sampling from
this distribution right we kind of know
i mean maybe to some extent we're
sampling what we're going to say next um
but i mean i think the important thing
to
internalize is
that we have a message that we want to
convey
right every time that we're using
language and um the way that we choose
to do that is
like at a specific information rate um
because we want to communicate
efficiently but we also want to make
sure that our message gets across um
without like having to repeat ourselves
or confuse someone or um you know making
them like spend an inordinate amount of
time processing what we're saying
um
and so
because of that like we're not going to
choose super low information words all
the time because that's just kind of
inefficient um you know like
i can i can uh say
all these filler words right with and
still get across a message but adding
like it's like that you know that person
that takes forever to explain something
just goes about it in a super
like slow and redundant way
don't make fun of my videos
what i was and what are you talking
about
um
so
i think that's something to to think
about and then sorry the second part of
your question i've already forgotten i
mean i i so i think i've what i've
understood is that if we look at just
the distribution of the next word that
is in all of language that is across
humanity everyone who's uttered ever
that first half of the sentence this is
the distribution of next word however
when i consider that i actually have a
message to convey that distribution
changes right
is that about the characterization of
why like my question would be why don't
i just sample from this distribution
right here given that if you know many
words are possible it will actually
result in kind of a diverse sampling
yeah i mean i think that you like first
of all i actually do think that uh in
the case of like a perfect language
model that you you could actually sample
from this distribution
um and
be fine um i think that there are some
uh
there are some artifacts that are a bit
strange like especially in models that
aren't trained as well with like this
this long tail distribution that like
that tail that isn't necessarily
learned all the learned very well like
what those natural probabilities are and
so you know you end up with
um
like
just oddities
um
and but beyond that uh i mean
i do think that
like
we're not
i mean we we're trying to modulate when
we speak like the amount of information
that we have per word right
um to keep it even and this is this is
not i mean this is something that is
perhaps not very obvious but it is
something that's like well studied in
psycholinguistics like how we yeah how
we convey a message
um and like the
coding that we will use
um within natural language uh and so
like
yeah we we uh
we take this into consideration when
choosing the next word um yeah not to be
too redundant or to be too surprising
yeah and to and and again to transmit
what we actually want to transmit right
because i have something that i want to
say and that means i can't just you know
blindly sample from the distribution i
would never actually transmit what i
wanted to say would it be would it be
possible that let's say if i could
hypothetically determine you know what
what kind of let's say i have a message
i want to transmit could i somehow
define the information content of the
next word given the message i want to
transmit and maybe also given the the
sentence you know so far t smaller than
or smaller than t well that's um i mean
that's actually usually what we're we're
doing um in
so in a task like abstractive
summarization which you know we see is
something that we experiment with
um we are conditioning on that message
essentially yeah that message being the
the
um article
right and so
it is like
we we are taking that into account when
we're trying to build our next word
um yeah and it is still like this
distribution should reflect the fact
that there is a message that we want to
convey and you know given that message
it sort of
it sort of reflects that you know maybe
this
word that without that knowledge
would have been very surprising but like
with that knowledge with knowing that
like we want to
transmit this message actually that
word
is
like what we would expect
yeah okay my my question of what i'm
trying to get at is
if i train my language model for
abstractive summarization right the
conditioning of the message is maybe
already in
not maybe in here if i use a decoder
only model but like
my question is still why is this
distribution here not enough
like why why do i need to cut out the
most likely things uh even though you
know sometimes i actually want to say
them
so i mean i think it's just to be more
human-like
like yeah that's okay that's the most i
can say is
yeah it's a it's fine right um
so you you
make you come up with and we're gonna go
back to these plots because i find them
super interesting as well you define
this typical sampling strategy where you
say okay we we have uh this thing here
which is the expected
information content of the next word and
then we're just trying to as closely as
possible match that so we're going to
select a subset of all the words that we
could pick
which closely match that expected
information content according to your
hypothesis and then we're going to
sample according to the new distribution
that only consists of the subset of
these words so in the video i think i
raised a point which is maybe more of a
i don't know if it's circular logic or a
philosophical point but
all our training data presumably of
these language models comes from humans
you know using language transmitting
information
therefore right shouldn't like if i now
train my language model and i use your
method to sample things and you claim
it's a human-like way of sampling things
shouldn't that
a result in the same distribution
and
b
shouldn't it sort of
the expected information content if i
measure before and after
like if i measure it in the training
corpus and then if i measure it as an
output of my model shouldn't that be the
same because presumably the training
corpus is already generated from humans
um i mean
yeah i think like
so yes i think that makes sense if i'm
understanding correctly um
and i also think we're kind of seeing
that like in um the earlier plots we're
actually seeing that
uh like if there is like an average
amount of information right according to
the model there's an average amount of
information that uh each word will
contain and i mean human text seems to
be
coming from quite close to
what um the model has learned that
average information rate to be
and do you did you investigate the
outputs of your model and sorry sort of
redid those plots
on the output of your model and observe
the same uh the same pattern yeah um so
that's like yeah that's something we did
as well um we looked at basically a few
different decoding schemes and saw what
the uh what these distributions looked
like for the outputs of those decoding
schemes and
i mean things like you know it's a
nucleus sampling with
um like very popular popular values of p
um looked similar and uh so did the ones
from typical sampling um we didn't i
think honestly they they do look they by
visual like visually they look
pretty similar which is nice um it's
also nice to see that certainly these
more
these vetted
decoding processes that have like stood
the test of time
are also actually
mimicking these distributions
um i think that if we wanted to
uh be robust about it we'd probably want
to
you know come up with some sort of
quantification for how different these
distributions are
and use that perhaps to see if that
correlates with how well these decoding
methods perform
in terms of things like human
evaluations
so can you tell us the story behind
these plots a little bit more because
you define epsilon in terms of an
absolute value yet here i see
values that are less than zero to both
sides so i didn't know which one is is
which yeah what's epsilon here that uh i
tried to make it clear in the um the
caption of the text but i i don't think
i i i did uh i mean i if if i guess the
correctly it's the it's the conditional
it's the expectation minus the actual
uh information
no so it's actual information
i would have gotten it wrong oh wait no
no i think you're right no no
okay so maybe you can tell us what what
does it because these are kind of so
it's it's uh more if i see this
correctly more sort of mass on on the
left side of these close to this
boundary uh which is really interesting
and then there's a long tail on the
right hand side what does that tell us
about um human language
i mean that's like a
very deep question and i'm not you know
i'm not entirely sure about what the
shape of this distribution means and i
think it's very interesting that this is
the the shape of the distribution um and
actually we did i mean we used a few
models here and all of them kind of did
look like this um where you had like
this peak and then sort of a long tail
um and
i yeah i mean i think that that's like
an investigation in its own right about
how humans use language
um but uh so yeah by the way it is
information content
uh minus entropy so remember like low
information content high probability
right so
um actually human language
uh tends to be to the
like on the higher probability side of
conditional entropy
so
this this thing right here yeah so if we
if we're way out on the right it means
that we actually transmit a lot of
information actually more than would be
expected yeah so there is it doesn't so
there is a long tail
of very high information
words let's say
do you think so because you in one thing
that i i skipped over that in the video
review but you make this point of humans
what they probably do is they want to
everywhere in the message they want to
have
kind of a constant information rate so
every word should approximately
transmit this this expected information
um so as you go through the sentence do
you think this could be violated a
little bit because humans
most of them do tend to have like a
short-term memory of three to four words
or so that they you know can keep keep
ready in the sentence maybe
uh i can transmit this super high
information word and then before my
receiver gets super confused i can
follow that up with like two or three
clarifications which uh which would be
then maybe here in the
lower information content but they would
be more
yeah i mean so
like i think it's hard to always avoid
uh moments of high information
i mean for example if if you're giving
if you think about this very literally
in terms of like what those words could
be
um you know they could be like someone's
name
right and that's kind of like you're
you're introducing someone that's always
kind of going to be like a high
information moment right um you have to
remember i mean we always forget
people's name people's names obviously
there's like there must be a lot of
information
uh in those names um it's a very
off-the-cuff explanation but
um i mean yeah so i think it is hard to
just
100 of the time
um avoid those instances but i mean this
is talking about sort of on average
um what we're doing when we're
constructing language and
i mean
so
i guess i couldn't say whether
in those moments
we want we try to perhaps on either side
um balance out
like with lower information words this
high information word because uh i mean
you know maybe maybe we do in order to
give the listener some time to
internalize this information
but they're also especially with
with speaking which is a different
domain than writing right there are
other ways that we can modulate high
information uh words right so we can
um elongate our speech to
basically spread out information over
time right and so it's not like here
we're just evaluating text
um so
you know we i think especially in text
um
we're going to see these
longer tails because
you can't
sort of distribute information
over
too many words in certain cases like in
the case of introducing a name
um yeah
and also it has to be said that you know
you can if you go to the left you get
into the super low information
words
and
there is only that many of them right as
soon as i'm at the and uh right there
there aren't that however there is in
fact a long tail just in the language of
super high information words that are
quite unlikely so maybe that plays a
role into it as well about these plots
you say you draw two
two different conclusions right here
which uh the first one is the peak
nature reveals that humans indeed tend
to form a language with per word
information content quite close to their
expected information content so this is
kind of you know here is data that shows
our hypothesis is correct
and the second one is the centering of
these distributions around the value
close to zero reveals that our
probabilistic language generators are
learning what this rate is which
and my point was a bit when in order to
make point one you need point two as an
assumption right you need you need to
claim
well i can only say this because i
assume our language models are modeling
the probabilities of language well
enough otherwise i could not conclude
point one likewise you couldn't conclude
point two without having point one as an
assumption
is this am i overlooking something here
well so
i mean i think the the point here that
we wanted to get across was really that
you know two things should be looked at
in these graphs which is
the centering of the graph and also the
shape of the graph um
and i mean
so i think there is there is
an assumption that kind of has to be
made here um i don't think it's quite as
severe as as what you've mentioned but i
mean it is sort of that
um this
enter this information rate
is kind of a ground truth of sorts um
but i mean
you know you could for example shift
like you could shift that entropy rate
you could shift the entire distribution
and still
um
you could shift h and all the p's and
you know all of uh all those numbers and
still technically get the same
distribution so that
um i agree with but like
i mean i think
like looking at
the peakiness of it clearly we're seeing
that you know humans are generating
language around a certain
that's something right
yeah
yeah like if what if it were centered
around two
instead of zero right
it would be as as peaky
well yeah i mean yeah as peaky then like
yeah like we'd probably be
uh that's probably sure that humans
communicate at like a very low
information rate right um or
yeah
so but no i mean it's around like
it does seem to be close to
this expected information rate
um and i think one other like the part
two is really trying to to show that
um
like
there's this
we would expect that if our
model
understands that you know humans
are speaking at around an
average information rate that um
that this distribution would be centered
around like on average it would be
predicting um that information rate for
a given word or like that information
content that probability for a given
word um and it does seem to be doing
this
cool yeah this is this is just a bit of
an it a knit or a nitpick for me it's
i'm i'm totally on board with i mean
it's pretty clear the language models do
model these probabilities relatively
correctly especially the ones in the
with the higher probabilities and uh i'm
i am actually i'm fairly convinced by
these by these
bring up plots
important and i actually like i spent a
long time thinking about whether or not
it was too circular um like you know
whether you could have one without the
other
um really and i mean i think like i
think at some point i came up with uh
some examples like some counterfactual
examples where actually you could have
one without the other and of course
now like i can't remember what they are
but
oh yeah it's uh it's it's uh i think i
think people understand what you're what
you're saying there and there's there's
definitely like a degree of freedom
there right there is definitely
something that could change
um that you know you could get those
same results and i think but i think
like that thing that could change would
be whether the information rate
um learned by the model is
like the quote
human information right the actual human
information rate and i'm actually not
entirely sure that's
important
it just has to be it just has to get it
right like relative to what it's
predicting the probabilities um for
words right
do you want to tell us a little bit
about the experimental results because i
have not gone into these at all during
the paper review uh things that you
would like to highlight or anything like
that
yeah um
so um like as janik mentioned there's a
new version on archive um where we are
we also present um
a few different values for
nucleus and top k and then like the same
you know same number of values oh yeah
the hyper parameters sorry about that no
no i think it was reasonable i mean the
thing is like you know there were only
so many human evaluations we could
afford and we thought like you know we
should probably test out more values of
our own method since no one has done
this before but like a lot of people
have looked at nucleus and top k
sampling um but then once it seemed like
okay this is worth this is research
worth doing we were able to get a little
more money and uh launch a larger human
evaluation so those results are are now
in the paper
um i mean i think one thing that was
really interesting for us was actually
just the
um the variety of values of tau that
worked well
i mean basically
like most values of tau worked well
there there wasn't like a
huge difference between all of them
which we thought was really cool you
know because in comparison to nucleus
and top k sampling those methods were
really dependent on
n and k and i mean i think there was
like a little like
like if you just look at the output of
these models you know if you have a
large tau
then uh maybe qualitatively you could
say that the the text is like
a little more
normal like a little more standard
um and then maybe a little more diverse
for low values of tau
but i mean basically it was just for
it was just interesting to see that for
um these two tasks at least that you
know variety like it wasn't you didn't
really need to tune tau that much
just kind of
kind of works it's important right
because that's one of the issues with
these things is that if if i have to
tune
the thing to every new task i do i i'm a
lot less certain in you know kind of the
generalization of this even within the
same domain yeah but if
it's it's interesting to hear and if
it's really kind of a handle on the
craziness that i get out of these models
uh that could actually be even a a cool
property right if you if you say
actually most values work but it is you
know it changes just the style i think
that that is a useful hyperparameter
rather than a nuisance like in nuclear
sampling
you know if i don't get it right
it's it's going to be crap
yeah well so i would like to think that
that's the case
i'm uh slightly slightly biased here
um yeah is there any i mean you you run
you're on various automated tests in
abstractive summarization and story
generation um most of the time the
typical sampling is on on top of the
pack sometimes not especially here in
the story generation on some of these
automated evaluations is that
kind of
an interplay between the evaluation how
the evaluation is done and the methods
or if that is that a property of the
task itself what can you tell us about
this i mean so i think a lot of these
metrics
i think a lot of these metrics can only
tell us so much
um and
you know the text that we end up
generating uh how it performs in terms
of these metrics i think like you'll see
for example in human text
you'll get reasonably different values
um like you can get reasonably different
values for things like repetitions and
within reason um and the text be
you know equally as good
uh at least
qualitatively so
like i think the
the
important i don't know i don't know if
it's important is the correct word but
uh one of the critical
things for us was like looking at at um
whether we could avoid this really
degenerate behavior with uh
with models um because i think that's
something that
that's like one of the bigger problems
in language generation
um is just like this tendency for
uh
for these methods to fall into
repetitive loops um and i mean we we
basically just like we we didn't really
see any of that
in
using our method
um and so i think that was an important
takeaway um so yeah i mean always kind
of uh performing well in terms of this
um in these metrics that show how
repetitive or redundant text is
um i think it is is what we would expect
right you know we're saying that like if
text is we want text to be about as
redundant as human text is
because that's like one metric you can
use uh to
quantify
information content right
so
[Music]
it was good to see that that like
at least
you know it's a necessary not sufficient
um criteria but it was good to see that
that it was met
yeah i was just looking like just now
looking at at perplexity and yours is in
bold and i was like wait a minute lower
perplexity is better usually but then i
realized i realized what you're what you
have to do here is obviously match the
perplexity of the of the reference text
as closely as possible so so the goal is
to be as close as possible to that
number which is really astonishing to
see because you know in machine
translation people are fighting for
point one perplexity or so for the new
state of the art and here it's a
difference of you know it's it's quite a
magnitude of difference between these
between these methods which is cool to
see and i think shows
shows quite well that in something like
story generation uh
these models might really just
not
overfit is the wrong word but over
produce um not as creative outputs
or maybe even degenerate ones as you say
i mean i think actually in the context
of machine translation and this is
something that um
that you know an experiment that i want
to personally perform um is
look at what the
like average perplexity of
the reference text is um right i mean so
and the generations right i mean so the
one thing about machine translation
is like typically we're evaluating um
on things like blue right not
not perplexity so much that we're
evaluating you know on the generations
themselves rather than the evaluation of
uh the reference text like
what the perplexities are um but i mean
it would be for me it would be
interesting to see what
um you know good generated text what the
perplexity of good generated text is
compared to
human like text
and i think in that case
they would actually probably both be
quite small
at least that's my my intuition
of course one
one uh
artifact that i think would
kind of get in the way of these
experiments is the fact that machine
translation often uses label smoothing
right um and label smoothing is is
basically like a form of of entropy
regularization so
um
it makes these distributions higher
entropy even
yeah
even if they shouldn't be yeah
and that actually i mean
basically
uh you can you can read other papers
about this it'll explain it but yeah it
is kind of it does interact with beam
search like it's like you know the match
of beam search plus label smoothing uh
tends to work quite well
but i think if
you were to
really perform these types of
experiments to understand what um the
types of perplexities for
machine training like for translations
uh good translations would be i think
yeah you need to do it with a model that
doesn't that hasn't had this sort of
artificial inflation in entropy
do you do you think um our training
objectives are
the correct ones
let's let's think of something like
story generation it's particular because
what i'm hearing now is that well label
smoothing but plus beam search
works but it's more like a hack to get
around the weaknesses of of beam search
without label smoothing do you
and and that is
you know something like i can maybe you
know get get behind do you think we have
the correct training objectives if our
goal is really to create a diverse and
interesting set of outputs do you think
it's a good strategy to train let's say
maximum likelihood and then sample using
something like typical sampling or
should we also change our training
strategy
um so i personally think that maximum
likelihood is a pretty robust
uh objective i mean in terms of like the
information theory
uh perspective i mean when you when you
are maximizing likelihood right you're
also minimizing kl divergence
so you are basically looking for the
uh
model
that
assigns the same information contents to
strings as as the empirical distribution
right so
it's like they're just equivalent um and
so i think if you take that into account
basically if you take into account
exactly what you're doing with your
objective
um and then from that you know go on to
okay well
uh given
given this distribution right how how
would we go about how would like we as
humans go about generating from this
distribution um or you know how would if
like you're generating an image like how
would nature go about like
generating from this distribution
i think you know that it's it's really
important to i don't think there's a
correct way necessarily
um
to go about training and decoding but i
think we really need to
take into account more their interaction
um and understand
like
what is going on within that interaction
yeah i mean i'm all on board because it
also means that we can use we can reuse
the same model for multiple let's say
tasks if we swap out our decoding
strategy
um can you tell us a little bit about
these plots and what we see here
yeah so this is um more just showing uh
the repetition values so kind of what i
was talking about earlier uh so high
repetition values would indicate that
we're getting into kind of like
degenerate loops like repetitive loops
so where the model outputs the same
thing over and over again and i mean we
really see this in story generation for
low values
of uh k and n
um where yeah exactly there so
you know this is
these are like
like repetition values of like point
eight so it's just like really just
spitting out the same exact thing over
and over again
um
and i mean yeah it's
like
i think that looking at this type of
behavior in terms of information theory
um it actually really makes to me it
makes it make sense why this is
happening right if we're saying that
we're always going to output the most
likely word like those are also the
words that just have like no information
content right and also like if i if i
come to you and i say look here is a
sequence of words it goes apple banana
peach apple banana peach apple banana
and then to ask you like what's next i
mean it's it's quite likely that you
know peach is the next thing and that
explains very well why if you keep
repeating you're sort of reinforcing
even that that repetition because as you
keep repeating the next repetition
becomes more likely yet
the transmission of information is is
almost zero yeah
and but i i mean i think one thing that
would actually be really interesting one
sort of experiments that we have yet to
run
is um to see you know if at the before
you get into these repetitions like if
you start with with something and then
you like if you start with
uh one
phrase and then
um go into typical sampling right can
you
prevent
um some of these repetitive loops
because you've now
come in with the objective that you want
to transmit like more information um you
you don't want to be you don't want to
transmit like a small amount of
information um which
is achieved by
like doing uh by giving high probability
low information words right so kind of
seeing if typical sampling can almost
help us break out of repetitive loops
although by your own
by your own what you wrote if you are
let's say in such a loop let's or at the
beginning of such a loop the
distribution would be extremely peaked
right and at that point typical sampling
would also go for the for the high uh
probability words or is that i mean
and honestly like i think it should
right like at that point but um i mean
this is kind of why it's like before you
get into
the repetitions right so it's like at
that point you know where
uh something like nuclear sampling might
decide like yeah like the lowest
information choice is
you know just to repeat what's already
been said um yeah if we can prevent
uh we can prevent those types of
behaviors
just some small technicalities uh
whether where i want to ask you if you
think that it's appropriate do you think
the absolute difference is an
appropriate measure or why did you
decide on that that's the first thing
second thing is do you think this cut
off this hard you know i'm gonna take
this many
words and then i'm gonna exclude the
rest and then i'm actually going to
sample from that bunch of words as if it
were like the original distribute like
with with their original logics so just
the technical implementation of the idea
what could be like what are arbitrary
choices what are what are things that
you did for a reason and how could they
be better
no i i think that's like a a great
question um why absolute value versus uh
you know squared distance
um and
and why the hard cut off um i mean to be
honest i think that this was the
original instantiation of the idea was
you know just choosing words from
like near the information content near
the expected information content and i
think
in order to really introduce this
concept into the literature it helped
um at least what i thought was that it
would help to have something that was
akin to
what most people are familiar with which
is nucleus and top k sampling right and
so
um for better or worse this method was
kind of like okay here's something
that's very parallel um that'll be easy
to understand you know it's it's uh it's
also just truncating the distribution
also like looking at the specific
portion of the distribution
um and that's where we'll sample from
now whether it's better to use the
squared distance i mean so
uh we ran some additional experiments
later on like after releasing this draft
looking at things like um the squared
distance uh and you know trying to come
up with a soft distribution
um and
yeah they they worked about like
about the same sometimes a little bit
like honestly i think i'm gonna have
like i think there's just a lot of
research to be done here um i think
there's a huge
uh huge
body of research that can be done in
sort of figuring out exactly what our
objective should be
um perhaps learning this objective like
learning what the correct
uh what the correct formula right here
should be
um and that's you know that's to come in
the future so i can't say that uh square
distance isn't better
um very well could be
all right
is there anything else you want to get
get rid of how can can people get
started with this is there code
somewhere there is code right i've seen
it yeah um there's actually code in
hugging face already
um so if you have i don't know if
they've uh released a version since it
entered the library i mean
it's been in there for about a month now
um
so i think if you have if you have the
transformers
the hugging face transformers library
installed from source if you have pulled
it in the last month um it'll be in
there and uh you know when you generate
if you just add in the argument typical
p equals something then you'll have
you'll have typical sampling and i mean
i really encourage people to play around
with it um i i mean i yeah you know
you're gonna expect me to say this but
i've actually just been really impressed
by the outputs of typical sampling um
just that they're they have been pretty
high quality from my perspective
um
and
interesting
cool
clara thank you very much for coming
here and uh thank you thanks for the
great conversation it was a pleasure
you know maybe you'll see uh another
update on archive with some of the
things you've pointed out
clean up some of my arguments
that that would be that would be
excellent lore for the channel
yeah
cool thank you
all right thank you
[Music]
you